my job is to get 8 billion people to
know me if enough people know me they'll
buy from me you you know that you're
playing small Amazon as you all know now
is the company of our world it will win
everything
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message decide to blow up
over to you grant cardone
also if you want to know what grant and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below you have to go
build self-confidence
[Music]
my jobs to get 8 billion people to know
me if enough people know me they'll buy
from me how many believe that I'm not
gonna be sick I'm not gonna be a slave
to one person or one vertical or one
niche or one partnership I have you guys
have the whole world at your access the
whole world and by the way if you can't
get South Korea to talk about you you
can't get South Indiana or Indianapolis
to talk about you there's people in
Korea that are tied to Hawaii that are
tied to Columbia that know somebody
Indiana and it can just bang out like
that and I also believe that if I could
get enough people to know me in one
market I think that there's something
that actually happens I think if you
could outfit you if you could get if you
could push out enough frequency about
your brand yourself your ideas to enough
people that you hit some critical mass I
don't know if any of you agree with this
but I think there's a spiritual
component to where if you can vibrate
through enough all of a sudden other
people start thinking I know that dude
I've said this for years if I can get
enough people a very small percentage of
the population to know me I think the
other 99% become convinced they know do
you think that somebody needs to reach a
certain like status before but no no no
you do not need to reach certain status
you need to assume the status now you
need to have the altitude right now to
be the professional it says hey I know
about fitness I know about plumbing I
know about trucks just take whatever you
guys are certain about and posts it out
of it and by the way if you're not
certain about it write an article about
what your uncertainties cost to you you
want to figure out every possible angle
but none of that's going to happen until
you guys make a decision to blow up and
none of the blow up is gonna happen
until you make a decision that money is
important because if you've got people
around you saying money's not important
ain't no way you're gonna do this stuff
because it hurts when nobody sees your
stuff you haven't decided to blow up
because you're afraid to fail and
disappoint people and that fear means
that you will take small risks you'll
take calculated risks risk that for
other people might seem really big but
you you know that you're playing small
and you'll grow you'll make progress
every year a little bit bigger a little
bit bigger but you'll never blow up
because you're afraid if you don't fix
it if you can't face that fear of
potentially disappointing people then
you'll just stay on your current course
instead of actually blowing up and you
need to decide if you're okay with that
or not I know because I'm talking about
myself I decided to do this tour I
decided to spend 90 days from January to
April going to 23 different cities and
helping entrepreneurs out in each city
and at the start it was supposed to be
just coffee shop meet ups or meet people
at a coffee shop say hey I'm coming to
Pittsburgh hey I'm coming to LA hand
coming to Cincinnati let's meet at this
coffee shop and that's historically what
I've done every time I've traveled I
went to New York and a great problem to
have was too many people showed up and
then ended up not being a fantastic
experience because a lot of people
couldn't hear me because a lot of people
didn't have seats to sit down in and I
didn't provide the experience that was
great I went to go meet my agent
afterwards and he said problem is you
haven't decided to blow up
problem is you're taking these small
calculated risks that if you do a
coffee-shop meet up and nobody shows up
it's okay
and if 100 people show up it's okay
you're not out anything you're not
risking anything you're playing small
you're making these slow steady gains
but you haven't decided to blow up okay
I want to blow up how do I do it I'm
ready you got a charge for the event you
got to do 23 events
you got to charge for them all right
away ah that is scary you know because
it comes against one of my greatest
fears which is disappointing people I
don't want to disappoint people if it's
a free coffee shop meetup and nobody
shows up or one person shows up I'm not
disappointed anybody but if I do a paid
event and one person shows up I don't
want to disappoint that person and that
fear is the thing is preventing me from
blowing up more than I should because
all the risks that I take our small
calculated risks that I get growth over
time but I know I could be doing more
and while it may seem like a big risk to
other people to me it doesn't feel like
a risk at all doing a 23 city tour where
I'm charging for events is a much bigger
risk and because they care so much about
disappointing people and the fear of it
it means I'll bring myself to each event
it means that I'm gonna over deliver it
means that whoever comes to each event
is gonna get insane value compared to
any other equally priced ticket I'm
gonna give everything of myself and it's
also the thing that I love the most
working with entrepreneurs face-to-face
is the thing that makes me come alive
it's great talking in front of a camera
and seeing you guys in your living room
or kitchen or bathroom or wherever
you're watching this but the one-on-one
work the face to face work is where
things actually happen and I'm on a
mission to help people move from getting
in their head to getting out there and
taking action from stop being such a
thinker and a planner and be more of a
doer from turning yourself doubt into
self belief that's what I'm doing I'm
coming to teach you all the stuff that I
know of how I built my business and
helped you get out of your own way and
start building
20:19 to be the year for you I'm great
at it it's what makes me come alive and
it's what makes the people who interact
with me go off and then have
life-changing experiences
but I'm still afraid and so I decided
I'm ready I decided that I'm ready I'm
ready to blow up I'm ready to play a
bigger game
20:19 will not look the same 2019 is
gonna be a much bigger year for me than
any of the year that I've had and that's
scary
but it starts with that decision and I
want you to blow up too if that's what
you want if you want to have a bigger
impact if you feel like you deserve more
if you feel like you know you're capable
of more that you've been playing small
that you've been hedging if you're okay
with that
great keep your growth I'm not judging
you but if you know you're capable of
more you've been playing small because
you're afraid this is important people
has to change I'm gonna give you a
three-step process to do it step number
one is decide to blow up you haven't
actually made a decision yet you are
hedging you're coming up with excuses
you come up with reasons all because
you're afraid and you haven't actually
decided here's what happens with the
brain when you are thinking about
something that is bold that is different
that is scary your heart wants to do it
like I want man I would love to do that
be so amazed if I could do that but then
your head gets in your way your head
tells you all the reasons why you can't
do that your head wants to keep you safe
your head wants to protect you your head
wants you to survive and it doesn't want
you to go off and do that scary thing
and so it's gonna come up with all these
logical reasons of why you shouldn't do
it you shouldn't do it because you don't
have enough time because you don't even
have resources because you're not ready
yet
you don't enough skills you don't have
education all of these are legitimate
reasons but they're just the surface
level deeper down it's just that you're
afraid and when you decide when you say
I am going to blow up I am going to go
do this bolt thing I have to make this
happen
then your head starts working for you
where you command your head to say brain
we're a genius up here we are genius
help me instead of hurting me when
you've decided with your heart that this
thing must happen now you can use your
brain to help you figure out the how
your heart will give you the why
your brain will tell you the how how am
I gonna do it and you want to focus your
head your brain on the right directions
because up until now if you haven't
decided yet
your brain is helping you figure out how
not to do it right how not to do it
that's what your brain is helping you
out with but once you've decided now you
command your brain to help you figure
out how to do it so step one decide that
you want to blow up step two use your
head to help you so you've decided what
is blowing up look like what is blowing
up in your business look like is it
hitting a million dollars in revenue is
it hitting one hundred million dollars
in revenue is it getting a million
subscribers on YouTube like what is
blowing up what does that version mean
to you what kind of metric can you chase
down so that you know that you're
hitting it and then you use your head to
say how will I go off and do this so for
me how do I go up and sell tickets in 20
to 23 cities when I'm doing this event
how do I sell those tickets how do I
make that happen using your brain to
help you great I can make videos I can
do my newsletter I can do advertising I
can connect with influencers I can make
with partners I can do media I can I can
I can I can I can I'm using my head to
help me what does it look like for you
what is blowing up look like and then
how can you use your head to figure out
a game plan in step number three is
announce it publicly announce it
publicly share it share it to your
audience share it to your customers
share it to your newsletter share it to
your friends
announce it publicly that this is what
you're gonna be doing for the next year
that this is your next big move when I
announce my tour and I'm gonna hit my 23
cities I gotta do it right I committed
people are buying tickets people are
showing up Nina I quit her job to come
and do this like it's happening I'm
committing to other people because you
will let yourself down way more easily
than you let other people down and so if
you're committing to the people on your
team you're committing to your customers
or could have been committing to people
who are following you you're committing
you're making a public saying this is a
declaration because if you say you
decided but you're not willing to share
it you haven't fully decided you're
still hedging you're still playing small
you're still repeating the same habits
to keep you on your current path if you
actually decided and you want to blow up
using your head to help you and now you
have to tell people about it you have to
make yourself accountable you have to
put it out there and risk disappointing
people
and risk failing that's the whole point
so step number one decide to blow up
step number two use your head to help
you and step number three announce it
publicly now I've got a really special
bonus clip for you that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question of
the day I want to know are you ready to
blow up are you ready to make that
decision if it's a yes I want all caps
yes with an exclamation mark in the
comments if you're watching on TV if
you're watching on mobile if it's hard
if you get to the comments positive
video loaded on your computer self
affirm write it down I want to see yes
all caps with an exclamation point in
the comments below let's get some energy
I want you to why I want you to feel I
want you to feel what it's like writing
why e.s exclamation point I'm ready to
blow up I want you to confirm to
yourself not just thinking I want you to
write it down and if you're watching on
TV or a tablet somewhere else and you
have to go to another computer it's even
better it's even better because you're
taking steps you're building some
momentum so put it in the comments ye-es
exclamation point post if you're ready
to blow up I'm excited
there is ridiculous confusion in the
system I am winning and will win at
all-time levels get ready you will tell
your grandkids that you once saw me live
like I mean that and by the way it's not
because by the way I don't by the way
real quick cuz I don't want claps for
that I need you to understand how I
think about that it's not because I
think I'm fancy or great I think it's
because I'm very common simple about one
simple tiny thing underpriced the
tension it's so grossly underpriced I'm
asking you let me tell you the story
about MTV when MTV came out in the early
to mid 80s how many people remember when
MTV was launched when empty when MTV was
launched the biggest bands in the world
the biggest bands in the world got
together for a dinner that one of their
managers told me about and decided that
they would not make music videos for MTV
because that was giving away music for
free that why would we spend money to
make a video put it on MTV but when
that's giving people the music for free
and they will not go out and buy the
record at the same token up-and-coming
artists Madonna Duran Duran and on and
on understood that it was where all the
attention of the youth was and it was a
gateway drug to the sale they understood
that MTV was a jab not the right hook
Facebook and Instagram at this second is
the most underpriced scaled jab in the
history of marketing except for one
other moment from 2001 to 2005 Google
AdWords was a ridiculously under priced
jab how many people here took advantage
of Google 2001 to 2005 raise your hands
so for you you really know that's how I
did it Wine Library had no money but
when you're buying people who want to
buy wine for five and ten cents a click
it works out real fast when it's that
underpriced
one company one company during that time
acted the way I'm aspiring to act right
now as Gary Vaynerchuk on social media
one company from 2001 to 2005 spent
enough to justify how underpriced it was
that company was a small book company
called Amazon Amazon as you all know now
is the company of our world it will win
everything it hasn't even begun
literally the only thing that will stop
Amazon is antitrust government
involvement otherwise it will destroy
everything
it got its fuel from Google 2001 to 2005
that occurrence is happening right now
on Facebook and Instagram and we're not
squeezing the juice out of that fruit
anywhere close at least we have picked
up the fruit if you want more grant
cardone and check out the top 50 rules
video I made on him the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there don't watch the news decide when
you leave here today to make the news
dude you don't get attention today you
have absolutely zero chance of being
successful